Speaker 1: Yesterday, we talked about this
hearing that took place on Tuesday in Ohio where
active AXA's showed up to support a bill to ban
any kind of business or employer or school from
requiring or even encouraging vaccination. It's
a crazy bill. And we talked about it yesterday
and yesterday we looked at some clips from a woman
named Dr. Tenpenny. And it actually slipped by me
that there was another really nutty moment where
a woman tried to prove that vaccines cause people
to become magnetized and thus metallic objects
will stick to you. But the demonstration failed
miserably. And so that you understand the idea, as
I understand it, is vaccines contain metal pieces.
And so when the vaccine is injected into you, your
body becomes magnetized and metal stuff sticks to
you. Now, even if the entire vaccine, it's just a
few milliliters, right? Even if the entire vaccine
was just metal, it's not enough to magnetize
your entire body. And what I mean by that is
if you suspend all disbelief about this and just
accept everything that's being injected into you
is just metal. It's not enough metal to make you
magnetized. OK, so but forget that for a second.
Here's them. The demonstration which fails. The
woman first tries to put the key on her chest and
it sort of sticks probably from surface tension or
sweat or grime or friction or whatever. But then
she tries it on her neck and it just falls off.
It's clearly not magnetized or she clearly is not
magnetized. And also, by the way, most modern
keys aren't even magnetic. So we'll talk about
that in a second. But take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Yes, vaccines do harm people,
by the way. So I just found out something
when I was on lunch, and I want to show it
to you. You were talking about Dr. Tenpenny
testimony about magnetic vaccine crystals.
So this is what I found out. So I
have a key and a bobby pin here.
Explain to me why the key sticks
to me. It sticks to my neck to.
You got this. Yeah, so if somebody
can explain this, that would be great.
Any questions?
Speaker 1: So a few things here,
first of all, when the key sort of sticks
to her chest, the chest is slightly angled
and because of the material of the key and
surface tension, and if she hasn't showered,
if she's slightly sweating, the key could stick
there for a moment. It doesn't mean that there's
anything magnetized there that it fails on her
neck. It just falls right off. But understand,
the most absurd part of this is most modern keys
aren't magnetic. Most keys are made of brass.
Brass is a zinc and copper compound. And when
you make brass, it's not magnetic. It's just it
just wouldn't work. It doesn't make any sense.
Like on the face value of this on principle,
it just completely fails because the keys aren't
magnetic to begin with. It's so embarrassing on
multiple levels that it is an incredible failure.
Here's a little supercute of the same woman.
Just check it out and it's just unbelievable.
Speaker 3: Yes, vaccines do harm people about
magnetic vaccine crystals. Explain
to me why the key sticks to me.
I can explain this, it would be great.
Any questions?
Speaker 1: When I see this stuff,
I do wonder whether, like as a society, we're
just regressing overall because this feels like
we're going back into, you know, the era of faith,
healing and witchdoctors in this type of stuff.
And it all comes down to the key, probably
stuck to her chest for a moment because she
didn't shower in the morning like that. That's all
that this is. And the answer for why it doesn't
stick anywhere else is this is all completely
absurd. But there's people who believe this stuff
and it's having real consequences. I
told you yesterday or the day before
that in vaccinated counties, including in places
like Tennessee, hospitalizations are up because
if you don't vaccinate enough people and it
seems like it's got to be at least 50 percent,
but ideally more unvaccinated people are going
to get sick and they're going to be hospitalized
and some of them are going to die. This type of
anti vaccine nonsense only makes that more likely